Dude,
let's build on our previous understanding of morphemes in word classes as we
move on to the particle. This class is in some ways a catchall category.
It includes a lot of little words that have some real function but not a lot of
content. Meaning they include conjunctions,
they include interjections like look that express more emotional content than
semantic content.
They also included type of word that's a little bit trickier to handle.
Many languages use small grammatical words that sit next to the word.
They relate to. An example would be a preposition in English.
What we know is prepositions usually describes some spatial or temporal relation
like above the table, below the table beside the table.
These are all prepositions.
The name actually doesn't come from anything to do with their meaning.
It comes from the fact that they have to sit right before pre the noun that they
are placed next to pose any type of grammatical word that works this way is
known as in ad position.
The name ad position just relates that the word is placed next to another word.
A preposition is placed before a post position is placed afterwards.
I've already mentioned a few prepositions in English,
but prepositions don't have to mark space or time relative to someone or
something in other languages. In Hawaiian for instance, prepositions,
Marcus' subject, the preposition, oh, Mark's a subject.
Whereas the preposition e marks and object. Here are two examples.
Here we see an example of a language using prepositions to mark a grammatical
feature we've talked about before,
so keep your eyes open for languages that do this,
that use ad positions rather than say inflectional affixes in Japanese,
the subject marker guy and the object Marker,
Oh appear after the words that they mark as subject and object.
So they seem to work like post positions at first glance and in both the
Hawaiian and Japanese examples,
we have particles that play the role of marking case for nouns.
Another group of words,
sometimes classed as a type of particle is the article articles include
indefinite articles like a or an English and the definite article V in English.
The classification is tricky because articles may exhibit many of the properties
of adjectives as well. This very quick overview of particles,
just introduced the concept,
but keep particles in mind as you move on to the next lesson where we'll start
putting together all the classes of words we've met so far.